this is where the attack happened in the
town of hawara in the occupied West Bank
Two Brothers From a nearby illegal
Israeli settlement was shot while
driving in a car Israeli forces say
they're looking for Palestinian Suspects
authorities immediately set up temporary
checkpoints and closed existing ones in
the area just south of nablis
unfortunately the terrorists continue to
attack innocent Israelis we will not be
silent we will do everything in our
power to protect our citizens we will
make sure that Israelis will be able to
live safely here in the land of Israel
shortly after the shooting Israeli
settlers in nearby areas burned down
several Palestinian homes many have been
injured since Israel's new far-right
government has approved the expansion of
thousands of new illegal settler homes
it says in response to this year's
attacks Sunday's shooting happened while
a U.S brokered meeting was being held in
Jordan between Israel and the
Palestinian Authority along with Egypt
and Jordanian officials it concluded
with their commitment to de-escalating
tensions by preserving the status quo
Al-Aqsa Moss compound and both sides
stopping one-sided measures for several
months including Israel's building of
new illegal settlements in the occupied
West Bank but just hours later Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu denied
the freezing of any settlement
construction during Sunday's cabinet
meeting Israeli leaders promised to
fast-track a bill that will allow the
courts to impose the death penalty for
offenses including attacks on Israelis
one of many exploited measures being
brought in by Israel's far-right
government that is showing no sign of
working towards a two-state solution
with the Palestinians
Al Jazeera West Jerusalem
Mustafa baguti is the Secretary General
the Palestinian national initiative he
says Israeli settlers are behaving like
armed gangs and they have the backing of
the Israeli government
the whole town of hawara
we had at least 110 people injured so
far
somewhere stabbed some were shot at some
were being beaten
and several homes were were burnt fires
are still going on around the city
around the town and inside it uh and uh
it's like it's a vicious fascist attack
the only way I can describe it is that
this is the behavior of fascist gangs
who are the Israeli settlers protected
and supported by the Israeli Army this
is something we've never seen before
and it is clear now that the settlers
themselves are sitting in the most
important positions in the Israeli
government
including smotrich who's a settler who
has become now in charge of the West
Bank
and the Israeli Army here as well as
being veeru has been classified before
as a terrorist and he is now the
minister of internal security in charge
of police
so the threat of Palestinians are in the
hands of illegal settlers they're simply
shooting and attacking people left and
right and they are loose completely the
Israeli Army is doing nothing to stop
them and even after the meeting the
nakaba all we hear now are statements
from Netanyahu and the prime minister of
Israel and others that they will not
respect what was agreed upon